si hay un interés político de australia
de digamos tener en cuenta el esfuerzo
que han hecho los australianos durante
todo el año en la pandemia recordemos
que australia el país con la mayor
cantidad de días en confinamiento sobre
todo esta ciudad del mi árbol incluso el
primer ministro de australia scott
morrison hace un par de horas expidió un
comunicado respaldando la decisión del
ministro de inmigración alex cox ha
dicho que la decisión fue basada
justamente en ese esfuerzo que han hecho
los australianos para garantizar la
seguridad de todos en cuanto a la
pandemia y que justamente esas normas
fronterizas que muchos las han
calificado como estrictas han sido en
pro de garantizar que la mortalidad sea
baja que la economía también crezca y
que se eviten casos de nuevos contagios
o también posibles brotes de la pandemia
sobre todo de la nueva variante de omic